[Music]
this was my last gig if it has happened
by now it's like a miracle was happen
[Music]
what happened electricity flicked off
all over the world
yesterday Ellie bought you a present
well my troubles seemed so far away now
it looks as though they're to say Oh
[Music]
what did you write you that I didn't
write it Paul McCartney wrote it at the
Beatles whoo
John Paul George and Ringo the Beatles
no stop it
yesterday it's one of the greatest songs
ever written Wow it's not Coldplay it's
not fixed you know who the Beatles are
and I'm in a really really really
complicated situation myself sorry I'm
just listening to Jack's new song what's
this one called
leave it baby well rock on Jack oh yeah
hi we should talk see we pay and you
write sauce and then you make a ton of
money and then we take most of it we
would like you to write something right
now she means no one's ever written this
many great songs how do you do it tracks
me like sometimes because that's someone
else's ghetto Souls
I don't mean half my not I for you to
bake up and love me but I'm a school
teacher if all the world's greatest
singer songwriter and not except for you
are
it's gonna be the greatest album of all
time
I've got two men who claim that the
songs are there let's see how this plays
out shall we
[Applause]
Commissioner please make some noise mr.
Jack
let me just give you this advice song
high school hey dude
hey dude are you sure hey dude it's so
much better dude it today
[Applause]
[Music]
you